celle où lendemain du drame une capitale
blessés meurtris mais une population de
boue
il est midi tout s'arrête dans le pays
pour une minute de silence à la mémoire
des disparus sur la place de la bourse
des centaines d'habitants converger
spontanément si rôle est en permanence
certains famille lancé un appel à
l'unité face à l'horreur d'autres
simplement pour se poser rené ce temps
se recueillir en silence déposer une
fleur ou allumer une bougie dire une
prière pour ceux qui sont partis sur le
sol tracés à la craie des centaines de
messages éphémère sans cesse renouvelée
ici cohabitent la peine et la colère le
courage et la peur un cocktail
d'émotions qui s'entrechoquent difficile
à exprimer
estelle lambardi s'avoue tout chambouler
dans ces tristes même
le home on veut qu on est tous là qu on
peut compter tout cela sur l'autre des
sanglots longtemps contenue un besoin de
réconfort largement partagée alors
yasmine et marine ont décidé de
fabriquer des pancartes et d'offrir des
câlins gratuits
c'est la seule façon qu'on a trouvée
pourrait répondre à ce qui est en train
de se passer on est venu on a pleuré on
a écrit on a allumé une bougie et on
avait besoin de faire quelque chose en
plus
plus loin jalal séjour est venue avec
ses enfants entre autres pour rassurer
sa fille anaïs qui a très mal dormi
parce que les gens croient ils sont six
ton si je vais leur expliquer que malgré
tout ce qui se passe bien faut garder
espoir qu on est là il faut continuer à
vivre partout dans la capitale les
forces de l'ordre n'ont pas chômé les
policiers bien sûr l'armée aussi appelés
en renfort pour assurer la sécurité
rassurer la population également le
niveau d alerte est resté à son échelon
maximum bruxelles donne l'impression
d'une place fortifiée devant le métro
partiellement rouvert les queues
s'allongent
tous les passagers sont soigneusement
fouillés avant de pouvoir entrer
depuis 24 heures les enquêteurs ont
beaucoup progressé
les trois kamikazes morts ont été
identifiés deux frères d'abord les
frères el batraoui au casier judiciaire
déjà bien remplie khalid est celui qui a
déclenché sa bombe dans le métro
son frère ibrahim et l'homme au centre
sur la photo captées par les caméras de
surveillance à l'aéroport l'homme à
gauche mord aussi vient d'être identifié
grâce à son adn il s'agirait de najim
lâchera oui l'homme au bonnet noir a pu
s'enfuir sa bombe la plus puissante ne
s'est pas déclenchée il est activement
recherché une autre bombe n'a pas
explosé
celle que les policiers ont retrouvé
dans la plante des kamikazes
un inventaire à glacer le sang quinze
kilos d'explosifs de tilter atp 150
litres d'acétone 30 litres d'eau
oxygénée des détonateurs une valise
remplie de clous et de vis ainsi que du
matériel destinés à confectionner des
engins explosifs un ordinateur et le
testament d'ibrahim el bahraoui ont
aussi été retrouvés dans une poubelle
il confirme ce que je soupçonnais les
enquêteurs les terroristes planifiaient
des attentats de plus grande envergure
encore mais se sentant traqué depuis une
semaine ils ont dû précipiter leur
action le bilan aurait pu être encore
plus lourd et jean-françois il sent
qu'on a vraiment affaire au même groupe
que celui qui a organisé les attentats
de paris
oui céline les liens sont évidents
d'abord sur parle des frères el batraoui
étaient connus pour leur facilité à se
procurer des armes a priori c'est eux
qui ont fourni les munitions de
kalachnikov qui ont été utilisés par le
commando des terrasses celui du bataclan
aussi à paris alors que si on parle de
najib lâchera oui il est a priori
considéré comme l'artificier des
attentats du 13 novembre
c'est lui qui aurait fabriqué les
ceintures explosives utilisées par les
kamikazes c'est donc un seul et même
réseau
beaucoup de ses membres sont maintenant
décédés ou encore ont été arrêtés cela
dit il faut quand même préciser que
toute menace n'est pas écartée il suffit
pour le comprendre de réaliser d'abord
que la belgique et par capita le pays
d'europe qui envoyait le plus grand
nombre de 10 à 10
c'est en syrie bien merci jean françois
vous en prie à voir